[Inaudible].
This week,
150 writers and academics signed an open letter published in
Harper's criticizing the current cancel culture.
The letter was equally praised in mocked.
Joining me now to react author don't burn this book, our friend, Dave Rubin.
All right, Dave. Good to have you on, you know, Dave,
this letter to me is fascinating because you have all of these
liberals who were saying, you know,
we refuse any false choice between justice and freedom.
We cannot have an intolerance society and they go on and on.
And this letter about, you know, the people I have to accept the opposing views.
I just find that hysterical because as someone on the right we've
had heart views censored for several years now, what's your take on this?
Yeah. Well, you're setting it up the right way because look any defense.
I know you're going to agree with me on this.
Any defense of free speech is good, especially right now. However,
most of the people on there who are lefties, liberals, progressives,
whatever you want to call them,
they've been pretty much silent as the mob has come for anyone.
That's right. Leaning. I mean,
we know right now during this show that there are people at media matters who
are waiting for you, judge,
Jeanine or me to say one word wrong so that they can send a mob and try to
cancel advertisers. They do this with Tucker.
They do this with everyone on the right. And it's like, where were you guys?
So what's happening now is that, although it's late, it's like,
they're suddenly seeing their universities crumble because Princeton and Harvard
and Yale, they're all having massive problems. We all see it.
And we know that all the statues are coming down as you were talking about
earlier and they're suddenly going, Oh,
the mob is starting to show up to my university and take down my statues and
they may show up at my house. So I better speak up,
but I have to tell them it's a little too late.
And I'll just say one other thing,
which is a couple of the people on the list have tried to cancel me. So, uh,
this thing was personal for me too.
Well, I got to tell you, I read your book, don't burn this book and I,
and I have to say, I love it. It's great reading. It is. And, uh, but,
but what's, what does it make sense to me,
Dave is the fact that, um, sorry about that.
What does it make sense to me is the fact that they wouldn't, uh,
at least attempt to join forces with those of us on the left,
because if they truly on the right, I should say,
because if they truly believe that there is no choice between justice and
freedom,
why not align yourself with people on the right with conservatives we're
stronger United aren't we.
Absolutely.
And that's what actually my whole book and my political evolution is about
because I,
on the left and then as I saw the left failing consistently on free speech
failing to stand up for the liberal principles that it purported to believe in,
what I suddenly found was, Whoa, look at this.
There's all these people on the right,
these conservatives and libertarians who I may have some political disagreements
with. That's fine. You, you read my book, you know, we disagree on some stuff,
but that's okay. But what do we believe in? We believe in the constitution.
We believe in free speech. We believe in free expression.
We believe in capitalism.
We believe that fundamentally America is a good experiment and that's all it is.
It's an ongoing experiment. And yeah, I think they're,
they're really afraid of being called conservative that in liberal
circles, that is still the scariest thing. Oh,
you're suddenly friends with conservatives. You must be a conservative. And,
and they've got to get over that because the ivory tower is crumbling and it's
going to crumble right on top of their heads.
Well, the amazing part of it is that the feelings are usually, I mean,
from what I'm about to know, and I'm kind of in the middle of things here,
it's from the left toward the right.
They don't want to hear people on the right.
I've never heard people on the right side.
I don't want to hear from that person.
I don't think that they should be allowed to speak at my child's university.
I mean, and, and we know from the time that Donald Trump was elected,
that you become, you know, people on fringe, you, they don't want you to be, uh,
they don't want to communicate with people I've had at my wedding,
don't talk or that my, my children's weddings actually,
they don't talk to me anymore. And it's not usually the right toward the left.
I mean, the intolerance is on the left. Am I wrong?
But the woke, no,
the woke condition is a mind virus. What is a virus?
A virus is very easy to catch and very hard to get rid of.
And that's what this thing is. It all kind of sounds right.
Everyone I disagree with is a racist. Well, that sounds pretty good.
That's pretty lofty. Once you accept those ideas,
you know that if you then walk away from it, you will be called a racist.
So it's almost a self hostage situation. Uh, but you know,
you also hit on something, which is that in the letter, the implication was, Oh,
well, we're not on the right. The right still has these problems.
I don't think there was one Trump supporter on there. It's like,
if you really want to be for a plurality of opinions,
couldn't you have found one Trump supporter or one really staunch conservative
that you would have believed, could have signed on to that thing. So it's a,
it's a disease of the left right now.
Thanks for being with us, Dave, thanks so much.
You're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.